Trascrizione: Laura Pasquale
Revisore: Els De Keyser
Buonasera.
Nella storia di Wired,
le parole che ricorrono
con maggiore frequenza
sono sicuramente innovazione,
tecnologia, rete.
Ma quando si parla con un innovatore,
allora i termini cambiano un po',
perché si inizia a parlare di sogno,
di visione, di creatività.
Vorrei raccontarvi una storia per capire
insieme come questi termini in realtà
siano determinati alla luce
delle profonde trasformazioni
che stiamo vivendo e che dovremo
affrontare nel prossimo futuro.
Questa è la storia di Tania.
Tania è un'artista di San Francisco.
A seguito di un incidente grave,
perde un occhio,
ha problemi di memoria breve.
Durante una conferenza
incontra Kevin Kelly.
Kevin Kelly è l'anima
visionaria, storica,
dei primi anni di Wired America,
è un grande teorico della digitalità.
Insieme condividono
una serie di passioni,
la fantascienza,
il cyber punk,
la scienza estrema,
le culture alternative.
Kevin mette in contatto Tania
con un gruppo di ricercatori
del MIT di Boston
e a quel punto Tania fa della
propria disabilità in realtà
una straordinaria opportunità
per realizzare il proprio sogno.
Quello che chiede Tania
a questi ricercatori
non è semplicemente
di ritornare a vedere,
quello che chiede Tania è un occhio
che sia il concentrato
di altissima tecnologia,
che possa zoomare,
che possa vedere ad infrarossi,
che possa scattare immagini
ad alta risoluzione,
video ad alta risoluzione.
In una parola, lei chiede di diventare
la prima cyborg della storia.
Quando decidiamo di affrontare
questa storia straordinaria,
di straordinaria umanità
e di straordinaria tecnologia,
incredibile tecnologia,
inizio a parlare con lei
per cercare un po' di capire
più in profondità la sua storia.
E lei mi parla dicendomi
di sentirsi una pioniera,
di sentirsi sull'orlo di un baratro,
con un'incognita gigantesca
di fronte a sé,
ma di avere completa fiducia,
di volere fare disperatamente
questo salto in avanti
per raggiungere la propria visione.
Lei mi sta parlando
in realtà di un'avventura,
ma un'avventura come
la intendeva Livingston,
cioè un'avventura
dei primi esploratori,
dove appunto il rischio, l'incognita,
in realtà sono il motore
che spinge in avanti,
non sono un muro che frena,
e quindi la possibilità anche
di considerare il rischio,
il fallimento,
e quindi giocarsi tutto, se stessi.
Ma non ci sono solo parole,
iniziamo anche
a scambiarci molte immagini,
e quella che ricorre nuovamente
con maggiore frequenza è questa:
ed è "Una donna sulla luna",
di Fritz Lang.
Questa immagine, questo film,
ha una storia abbastanza particolare
nel rapporto con la scienza,
perché parlando di fantastico,
questa è stata l'ossessione di uno
dei più grandi scienziati del Novecento,
proprio un'intima ossessione
che ha caratterizzato
completamente tutta la sua ricerca.
Lui è ovviamente Von Braun,
noi molto probabilmente,
non in quei modi, non in quei tempi,
saremmo andati sulla luna, senza
il film, appunto, "Una donna sulla luna".
Ma quello che compie poi Von Braun
è un altro passo molto interessante,
cioè Von Braun capisce che una visione
può essere condivisa, può contagiare,
e quando la visione di un singolo
diventa una visione collettiva,
allora diventa veramente
un'idea difficile poi da frenare.
Quindi si affida a un altro architetto
dell'immaginario e del fantastico,
che è Walt Disney,
che ne fa un documentario
per spiegare alla gente comune
che cos'è realmente l'operazione
"Uomo nello Spazio".
Non è neanche un caso
che lo stesso Walt Disney
dedicherà alla creatività e alla visione
forse uno dei suoi lavori più belli,
che è appunto "Fantasia".
Ma in realtà, come portare tutta
questa storia, tutti questi elementi
che non sono solamente
la storia di Tania,
la sua avventura, la sua disgrazia,
la sua fiducia
nella tecnologia e nel futuro,
come, in qualche modo,
trovare il "mio" Walt Disney,
cercare di comunicare e contagiare
i lettori, per cercare di fornire loro
esattamente tutti gli strumenti
per poter comprendere a pieno,
di godere anche
emotivamente di questa storia.
Lui è Dan Winters, uno
dei maggiori ritrattisti americani,
insieme abbiamo lavorato su molte
storie nei primi anni di Wired.
Decidiamo quindi di lavorare
su un concetto molto semplice,
poche immagini,
lavorare molto
sull'elemento fantastico,
ma porre l'attenzione
su un ritratto naturale,
non post-prodotto,
non photoshoppato,
non alterato di Tania,
e costruire invece
tutto quel fantastico,
come una cornice,
come una decorazione,
che potesse in qualche modo
aiutare il lettore
a comprendere bene
tutti questi riferimenti.
Iniziamo, alla faccia della digitalità,
a costruire materialmente -
Dan Winters è un maker,
una persona,
un artista a tutto tondo,
non è solo un fotografo, è anche
un falegname, un carpentiere -
iniziamo a costruire
questo frame, questa cornice,
alla fine sarà perfettamente funzionante.
L'idea era quella di poter
sfruttare un'applicazione interattiva
che stavamo studiando
in quel periodo per la rivista,
quindi dare la possibilità attraverso
un tablet al lettore di entrare,
azionare questa macchina,
accenderla,
godere di filmati, documenti extra,
proprio giocare
sullo scambio di informazione,
sullo scambio di contenuti.
Quello che alla fine è arrivato,
ci siamo purtroppo
dovuti accontentare
dell'interattività della carta,
quindi posticipando
questa applicazione che sarà
disponibile dal prossimo 3 dicembre,
ma il lettore aveva la possibilità
di godere di questo ritratto,
semplice,
il fuoco di attenzione
va immediatamente
a questa differenza tra i due occhi.
E poi c'è questo portale,
attraverso il quale si passa
all'impaginato, a una doppia fotografica.
L'idea è proprio di giocare con la carta,
la digitalità non manda in pensione
nessuna tecnologia, nessuna tecnica.
Qualcuno diceva prima di come
la digitalità in realtà
si stia sovrapponendo
al mondo delle cose,
e stia in qualche modo,
di contrappasso,
cercando di guadagnare matericità.
Quindi abbiamo cercato
di pensare di utilizzare il testo
come un manuale di istruzioni.
L'abbiamo inserito in modo mimetico
all'interno dell'impaginato,
in forma ridotta,
dando la possibilità al lettore
di entrare emotivamente,
in maniera immersiva,
come è ovviamente
una delle caratteristiche
della carta e della lettura.
Questo modo di utilizzare la grafica,
l'illustrazione, l'infografica,
è un modo abbastanza
caratteristico della storia di Wired,
soprattutto di Wired Italia,
ma non è migliore o peggiore
di altre, ovviamente,
riviste che hanno
un contenuto scientifico.
Noi abbiamo scelto questo modo
e siamo unici e diversi dagli altri.
Abbiamo ovviamente utilizzato
non solamente tecniche,
come ripeto, digitali,
ma abbiamo utilizzato la scultura,
la pittura,
la pittura su legno,
addirittura la performance,
non solo la fotografia
e l'illustrazione.
Ma questa sorta di onda creativa
che parte dal mio dipartimento,
coinvolge gli artisti che noi pensiamo
siano i più adeguati
a raccontare certe storie,
non finisce, perché
è una sorta di onda di ritorno.
In questi 4 anni
abbiamo capito come i lettori
in realtà siano stati
realmente contagiati.
E abbiano iniziato a risponderci
proprio utilizzando la creatività,
utilizzando, diciamo, le immagini.
Un caso emblematico è questa storia:
avevamo dichiarato di avere
intenzione di approfondire
un pezzo sulla Pop Economy,
e un lettore ci scrisse che forse
il modo migliore di visualizzarlo
sarebbe stato
creare una sorta di compendio
di economia domestica,
tanto in voga negli anni '50.
L'idea era che l'assonanza
tra i riferimenti era perfetta.
Abbiamo accettato la sfida,
abbiamo trasformato la nostra storia,
addirittura abbiamo
trasformato la copertina,
creando una sorta
di copertina di un libro
all'interno di una copertina
di una rivista.
Sempre con questo gioco,
ma il gioco non finisce e inizia
solo tra noi e i lettori,
i personaggi delle nostre storie,
questa è la più grossa sorpresa,
le persone di genio
hanno voglia di giocare.
Hanno un rapporto col fantastico
e con il gioco che è incredibile.
Loretta Napoleoni,
che è una serissima economista,
si è prestata in stile
Mad Men a questo gioco.
Ma Hugh Herr, ma Giovanni Bignami,
potrei farvi una lista infinita,
anche Riccardo Prodam
era stato una delle nostre copertine.
La cosa però più importante,
come dicevo,
è che forse la creatività deve
essere considerata una qualità,
che appartiene, un'arma
utile ad ognuno di noi.
Robert Musil scrive
questo romanzo che è fantastico,
che è L'uomo senza qualità.
È una fotografia proprio del periodo
della prima rivoluzione industriale,
cioè l'uomo di qualità
è l'uomo della produzione,
l'uomo del controllo,
l'uomo della macchina,
l'uomo dei numeri,
l'uomo dell'applicazione della formula
e della certezza del risultato.
L'uomo del controllo della massa.
Dall'altra parte c'è che cosa?
C'è l'uomo senza qualità,
che è il singolo, il visionario,
è una persona che
di fronte a una problematica
offre una molteplicità di soluzioni,
quindi non è utile,
è un uomo inadeguato.
Ma, e qua Fritz Lang mi aiuta ancora,
noi stiamo vivendo questo passaggio
tra la società industriale
e la società digitale,
e ci è quasi impossibile
a volte fermare
il ritmo frenetico del cambiamento,
e sappiamo proprio
che il cambiamento forse
è l'unica vera costante di questi tempi.
Lo stesso concetto di massa
è praticamente frammentato,
a scapito di cosa?
Della singolarità.
Non esiste più una pangea
di un pensiero collettivo,
ma esiste invece un arcipelago
composto da una miriade di atolli,
che sono rappresentati
da ognuno di noi,
attraverso le tecnologie,
attraverso la rete,
attraverso la comunicazione
e la condivisione
hanno parola,
utilizzano la propria creatività.
E vi lascio con questa immagine,
un'immagine perfetta
di quello che è la creatività:
La carta del folle,
il visionario che entra in trance
di fronte alla propria visione,
il fedele compagno che lo avverte
che forse sta compiendo
un passo forse fatale.
Ma la meraviglia di questa carta
è che è un'azione sospesa,
nessuno sa come in realtà
questa storia vada a finire.
Se io vi lasciassi qualche secondo,
voi capireste qual è
il reale finale di questa storia.
Se io lo chiedessi ad ognuno di voi,
avrei un centinaio di finali diversi,
ed è questa la meraviglia
della creatività,
e cioè, fare dell'unicità
e della diversità
l'unica e sola risposta possibile.
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)